chadwick moore is a columnist with the
spectator and he joins me now
hey chadwick okay give it to me is this
an act of love or is this really just
about consequence-free sex
i mean why stop at the vasectomy i think
it just lobbed the whole thing off and
become trans that's what you should do
if you really love your wife and want to
show her what a supporter of womanhood
you are and of the female cause uh i
would also wonder i would love to see uh
how the washington post and this
reporter who is clearly a bit too
excited about the idea of men uh being
mutilated in a clinical setting
unnecessarily how would she react if
women were doing the same thing if there
were a trend of women that were getting
their tubes tied to show how much they
love their husbands and maybe that's not
such a bad idea why how would they react
to that of course we know it would be
you know this ho these women are
horrible and self-hating uh and uh of
course we can laugh at these men who are
doing this as well uh and uh it fits
perfectly in line i mean
consequence-free sex is what drives the
left it's their religion uh it fuels
almost everything they do and of course
they uh believe in population control
they want fewer people on the planet of
course populations aren't growing in
rich western countries except by illegal
immigration uh so i wonder how if you
were to take this to parts of the world
where the population is exploding like
in i don't know sub-saharan africa or uh
central america i wonder how those men
would react to being told that they
should have a vasectomy uh to show how
much they love their women
chadwick isn't this really good politics
because if you have all these woke
liberal
men in bike shorts that get vasectomies
and not have kids but you have
conservative men like me who have nine
kids isn't that great because you have
conservatives being born and you're not
having liberals not having kids
good politics well i mean that
yeah that's why we're not like super mad
about it right because they're just not
breeding and that's fine and i hope that
these men get you know a free uh box set
of harry potter when they go in for
their snip and some soylent and whatever
else they like to do with their free
time um fine if that's what you want to
do go for it uh but um
uh it does make you less of a man i'm
sorry
all right so so chadwick you saw the
video of aoc who's out there saying
listen we want to save the environment
and so let's not have kids
give me your take on aoc saying don't
have kids save the environment
yeah well this is something i mean at
least they're finally out in the open
with this you know the left has sort of
secretly been saying this for a long
time they really think that the way to
save the planet is fewer people uh of
course that doesn't sound very nice but
you know they've they've become so uh
brazen lately with what they truly
believe and what they're truly about you
know they've really kind of uh gone off
the deep end that she i think she's
saying what she's been learning in
college and and what has been
circulating around the progressive
caucus for a very long time uh they want
fewer people they want less people and
there's many ways to do that uh this one
just sounds a little nicer than other
tactics that the left has tried in the
past and
sadly successfully tried in the past
hey chadwick some would say save the
world have no kids others would say save
america have less liberals but listen
hey thank you for joining me tonight i
appreciate it